bonjour docteur ramon merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france alors vous
les avez certainement entendu comme nous
les annonces ce soir du président de la
république déjà l'hommage aux soignants
et puis une prime exceptionnelle pour le
personnel soignant il promet un plan
massif d'investissement dans l'hôpital
et la revalorisation des la majoration
des heures supplémentaires votre votre
réaction quand aux annonces du chef de
l'état bien c'est à dire que c'est une
annonce qui c'est une annonce qui ne
risque pas d'être oublié et on sera là
l'a rappelé en temps utile quand quand
la crise sera passée
c'est un investissement pour le moment
qui n'est destinée qu'à l'hôpital et je
pense que ce site était bien si le
président n'avait pas oublié la médecine
de ville qui payent un lourd tribut
actuellement à l'épidémie il ya quatre
médecins libéraux qui sont décédées est
qu'ils ont travaillé depuis maintenant
un mois avec des masques chirurgicaux
qui sont des vraies passoires pour le
pour le coc vide 19 et est donc
actuellement on est condamné à bricoler
avec des dons de masques qui nous
viennent des patients ou de sociétés
comme swatch france là qui vient de nous
proposer de nous livrer dix mille
masques demain à clamart con qu'on
pourra répartir entre tous les
professionnels de santé qui en ont qui
en ont bien besoin
on est un petit peu on est heureux que
le prêt que le président prenne
conscience qu'il faille investir
massivement dans le système de santé
d'autant plus que normalement des
pandémies comme celle qu'on a connue
c'est la troisième en quinze ans est la
plus grave mais normalement on sait
qu'on est à la merci d'une pandémie et
que
avoir des millions de masques en réserve
pour protéger les soignants mais aussi
pour protéger la population
c'est un luxe que on ne devrait pas dont
on ne devrait pas se passer ça coûte 15
1 millions d'euros et sur un budget de
la santé qui est 245 milliards je pense
que ça a été une erreur de rayer ces 15
millions d'euros vraiment à vous avez
vous même un été testés positifs au
cours d'un virus il ya maintenant à plus
d'une semaine la question est simple
comment comment allez vous ça va bien là
c'est le onzième jour je commence
c'est le premier jour à peu près où je
suis à peu près correct il reste qu'il
ya quand même une immense fatigue ce que
ceux qui ont dit que c'était une grippe
je peux vous dire j'ai rarement été mis
sur le flanc par une grippe pendant
pendant 11 jours et est rarement épuisé
comme ça donc encore personnellement je
m'en sors plutôt bien alors vous vous
êtes traité à la chloroquine cette
molécule qui fait débat en france
utilisé d'habitude dans les traitements
contre le paludisme christian estrosi
lui aussi ses traités à la chloroquine
il dit que le médicament lui a été
bénéfique
est ce que c'est votre cas écoutez bon
là la chloroquine on va pas on va pas
revenir dessus parce que tout le monde
espère que le l'idée du professeur
ajoutée est la bonne mais pour le moment
aucune étude sérieuse scientifique n'a
été jusqu'au bout et
le professeur raout doit être le premier
à reconnaître que son étude de 24 sur 24
cas dans des noms n'est pas une haie et
qu' il a il a effectivement cette cette
idée sur l'efficacité de la chloroquine
s'y associer à l'azithromycine mais pour
le moment attendant on dit toujours que
les études avec de nombreux cas soit à
mener et soit conclusive avant 2 avant
de généraliser cette cette prise de
chloroquine personnellement je les
prises pendant deux jours et demi et
j'ai arrêté au bout du troisième jour
parce que je je supportais pas les
nausées générés par la part la
chloroquine j'espère que c'est pas c'est
pas le cas pour les autres on va faire
que les câblages et j'ai arrêté les
frais au deuxième jour et demi
j'aimerais avez vous revenir sur le
thème du confinement enlisait pénurie de
de masquer un sur tout le territoire et
peu de dépistage massif est ce que le
confinement c'est à l'heure actuelle la
seule solution
oui oui oui le confinement c'est la
il y a il ya une vingtaine de jours 1
soir / sur lci je m'étais interrogé
publiquement et je pense que c'était une
erreur de dire est ce que on ne ferait
pas mieux de d'ouvrir les vannes de
protéger les personnes fragiles et de
laisser le virus circule et
c'est un choix qui a été fait par par la
hollande jeu j'aimerais bien suivre avec
attention comment ça va se passer chez
eux mais en tous les cas je pense
sincèrement que le confinement est une
bonne chose et en tous les cas la seule
solution actuellement pour enrayer cette
épidémie
merci beaucoup doctorat monde avoir été
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france et je
rappelle que vous êtes bien sûr médecin
généraliste et président de la
fédération des médecins de france merci
beaucoup